foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today I've got something
special for you a complete documentary
on the history of Hogwarts and the lives
of all four Founders godric Gryffindor
Salazar Slytherin Helga Hufflepuff and
Rowena Ravenclaw in this video I've left
no stone unturned in the discussion of
Hogwarts tumultuous history and have
included everything I could possibly
find on the school's four Founders by
the end of this video you're going to be
an expert I'm going to kick things off
by discussing how the school was founded
then begin diving into the rich
histories of each founder zip back relax
and enjoy Hogwarts was founded at some
point during the 10th Century it was
built to Hidden off somewhere in a
Scottish Highlands the exact location is
never actually revealed and this was
because the 10th century was a time of
hardship for witches and wizards during
this time every day witches and wizards
were being persecuted by Muggles who
were intensely hostile when it came to
witnessing sources of magic in order to
further protect the staff students and
school itself additional precautions
were made in the form of charms helping
to further conceal the school for muggle
trespasses if a muggle would have just
happened to stumble upon the school
grounds they would only see ruins and
signs warning them to stay away Hogwarts
was founded when four 10th Century
witches and wizards got together and
decided that they had in assaulting her
own words the self-same yearning to make
the world's best magic school these
Founders were godric Gryffindor Rowena
Ravenclaw Salazar Slytherin and Helga
Hufflepuff thus Hogwarts was born the
name Hogwarts actually came from founder
Rowena Ravenclaw but a dream where a
warty hog led her to a cliff via Lake
it's also been speculated this is how
they chose the location for the school
as well after its establishment like
with any institution a Crest was formed
for Hogwarts emblazoned upon the school
Crest other words Dre
which roughly translates to never tickle
a sleeping Dragon Rawling revealed the
true meaning of this motto in an
interview the name is just an idiom
derived from that sleeping dogs lie it's
a magnification if you will it basically
means don't stir up trouble don't open
up a can of worms don't stir up a
hornet's nest and definitely don't play
with fire if you tickle a sleeping
Dragon then you are probably only
causing problems for yourself problems
that can be easily avoided if you simply
didn't tickle a sleeping Dragon anyway
after the founders who are close friends
found at the school they decided they
would each create and head their own
house which would represent a
personality trait and skill that they
wanted to nurture and it just so
happened that despite being close
friends each founder happened to Value
very different things which created
quite an interesting and diverse array
of students at the school Gryffindor
students embodied bravery and chivalry
Ravenclaw intelligence and wit
Hufflepuff loyal
play and Slytherin the values of being
Sly and cunning and for years the
Hogwarts founder served as head of their
respective houses and sorted students
into their houses manually however when
it occurred to them they wouldn't be
around forever they needed to come up
with some sort of way that they could
continue to sort students when they were
no longer around thus the Sorting Hat
was born godric Gryffindor pulled his
completely normal hats off of his head
and made the suggestion to the other
Founders that using their Collective
magic they enchant the hat and turn it
into a sentient being it was important
to the founders that the houses they
formed would continue to follow by the
beliefs from which they were based these
virtues or inherent characteristics are
best summed up in the Sorting Hat's own
words by Gryffindor the bravest were
prized far beyond the rest for Ravenclaw
the cleverest would always be the best
for Hufflepuff hard workers were most
worthy of admission and power hungry
Southern loved those of great ambition
essentially how it works is this upon
ahead it will begin to analyze your mind
and place you in a house based on how
closely you resemble one of the four
Founders if the Hat senses great bravery
Gryffindor is a likely choice if the Hat
senses great intelligence Ravenclaw is a
likely choice if the Hat senses that
someone is a hard worker Hufflepuff is a
likely choice and finally the Hat senses
that someone is hungry for power then
Southern is a likely Choice after the
Sorting Hat was put in place it made
things much easier for the founders and
it couldn't have come at a better time
as the founders were beginning to have a
bit of a falling out but before we get
into that let's take a look at the four
founders of Hogwarts a little bit closer
up to four founders of Hogwarts there
are none quite as beloved as godric
Gryffindor he was one of the most
powerful Duelists of his ERA with both
the wand and a sword and the students of
his house have proven themselves time
and time again as champions of The
Wizarding World as they defeated the
likes of Garrett Grindelwald Lord
Voldemort and many a dark wizard but
despite his impressive Legacy many of
his most famous Feats and achievements
have all but been forgotten godric
Gryffindor was likely born sometime
before the year 960 CE in the village in
the west country of England unlike some
of his other co-founders like Salazar
Slytherin the exact location of godric
gryffindor's birth is pretty easy to
determine in commemoration of his long
years of service to The Wizarding
community that small village in the west
country was renamed to godrick's Hollow
in his honor and it was actually home to
many of the most famous gryffindors of
the 19th and 20th centuries the
Dumbledore family perhaps as early as
1864 resided in godric's Hollow as well
as the Potter family who lived in a
small family Cottage until Lord
Voldemort's fateful attack during his
life godric Gryffindor must have shared
the same challenges as other witches and
wizards of the time mainly the
persecution of the community by Muggles
who were increasingly fearful full of
those who could wield magic throughout
his life godric Gryffindor surely faced
the hatred of the non-wizarding
community but interestingly when
compared to one of his childhood friends
Salazar Slytherin godric never tried to
retaliate in fact amongst the four
Hogwarts Founders godric was the most
vocal in his support of the Mughal
community and mughal-born wizards that
alone has led some to question
gryffindor's own Heritage some would
suggest that Gryffindor might have been
a Half-Blood although this is extremely
unlikely one of his closest friends was
as we've already mentioned Salazar
Slytherin who spent nearly his entire
life working on behalf of purebloods as
a young man in the decades prior to the
founding of Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry godric became
quite an icon with his skills with both
The Sword and the wand he was renowned
as one of the greatest Duelists of the
era and with his massive broad shoulders
and red hair that was often described as
a lion's mane he was an intimidating
presence in any Arena even though he
could defeat almost any opponent in a
magical duel Gryffindor often opted to
use a simple sword especially if he was
facing off against a muggle godric took
great care to preserve honor and respect
even in combat the very traits that
would go on to partially Define his
house at Hogwarts sometime before the
year 990 CE the year Hogwarts was
founded godric Gryffindor found himself
in correspondence with three of the
greatest Wizards and witches of his era
one was his longtime friend Salazar
Slytherin the other two were Helga
Hufflepuff a witch from Wales who was
highly talented in charms and Rowena
Ravenclaw a witch from Scotland who had
an Infamous falling out with her own
daughter the four were already famous
for their abilities and together they
hoped to combine their skills in order
to teach future generations of witches
and wizards each of these founding
members of Hogwarts had their own vision
for education and and with that we're
given leeway in how they instructed
classes in their early discussions it
must have been apparent that godric
Gryffindor just as his reputation as one
of the greatest sword Jewelers at the
time seemed to indicate hope to find the
bravest and most determined students
while some members like Helga Hufflepuff
didn't put such heavy burdens on freshly
enrolled students as Gryffindor did and
if there's a flaw in the legendary hero
of England then that's perhaps the
largest one in creating his house
Gryffindor hoped to establish a legacy
that would last for centuries to come
one centered around the Warriors ideals
that he himself embodied when he
withdrew his ruby inlaid sword in combat
but when compared with our own modern
concept of education and the role that a
teacher should play in the students
development godrics could be said to be
Farm outdated some might even say that
godric wrongly conflated his own Delight
in dueling and battles to the death as
Brave so when he served as the leader of
his house he might have taught his
children to solve problems by fighting
their way out of the situation instead
of using other tactics like diplomacy
which actually might have saved more
lives whatever your take on godric's
education philosophy may be it's hard to
deny the effect the wizard had while
other houses like sutherin gave rise to
some of the most terrible dog Wizards
the world would ever see Gryffindor
brought about the likes of Albus
Dumbledore James and Lily Potter and
Minerva McGonagall as the school grew
Gryffindor Southern Hufflepuff and
Ravenclaw discovered a handful of
challenges that they would need to
overcome first of all even though
Wizards and witches tended to be longer
lived in their muggle counterparts they
would inevitably die the founders
wondered how students would be sorted in
the Years following their deaths during
those discussions it's likely that the
other Founders simply wanted their heirs
the teachers that would succeed them to
select students on their behalf but
Gryffindor and a different idea he
popped the brown leather hat off his
head and together they imbued it with
the power to decide which house a
student would belong to this of course
is the Sorting Hat but Gryffindor laid
another secret enchantment on the hat
and it had to do with this sword
sometime just before or sometime during
his time at Hogwarts godric Gryffindor
had commissioned the creation of a
silver sword in later years it would
become known simply as the Sword of
Gryffindor but during that time the
Goblins who had created the blade might
have known it as ragnarok's sword after
all Ragnarok the first one of the
greatest silversmiths of the age had
spread a rumor amongst the goblin
community that the sword was actually
his and Gryffindor and stolen it the
Goblins had been so anchored by the news
that a group of easily manipulated
Goblin thugs tried to knock godric
unconscious and ripped the sword from
him Gryffindor famously withdrew his
wand in response
and cast a spell on the woefully
outmatched Goblins sending them back to
Ragnarok with a threat of their own if
the goblin ever tried to steal the sword
again godric would drag its blade
through the lot of them and leave them
lifeless on their dust-covered Foundry
floor when Gryffindor joined the other
three founders in enchanting the Sorting
Hat he added an additional bit of magic
whenever a true Gryffindor was in need
of help they could reach their hand into
the hat to withdraw ragnarok's sword now
godric was never highly regarded for his
Mastery of divination but the
enchantment he put on the Sorting Hat
seems to indicate otherwise why else
would children at Hogwarts need quick
access to a weapon that was powerful
enough to slay a basilisk again the same
critics of godric's Legacy might simply
suggest that he was a combat obsessed
wizard of the Dark Ages who couldn't
quite distinguish what was appropriate
for his students but that hardly seems
to be right after all the time of godric
Gryffindor was filled with more than
enough enemies to make a young wizard
fear for their life with witch hunts
looming on the horizon and dark Wizards
from within the English magical
Community sprouting here and there
godric had every reason to worry for
future students at Hogwarts but as the
years passed at Hogwarts Gryffindor
faced a new challenge with his oldest
friend Salazar Slytherin was becoming
increasingly intolerant of Muggles and
half-bloods he didn't like the idea of
Hogwarts admitting anyone other than
pure Bloods if we look past the simple
Prejudice and try to figure out why
Slytherin held such an extreme opinion
it's likely due to his own painful
experience with Muggles in his youth
whatever torment he faced to the hands
of the non-magical community certainly
didn't excuse his own extremism but it
does add an extra sense of tragedy in
the end Gryffindor along with the other
founding members of Hogwarts decided
that enough was enough and Slytherin
left the school that unfortunately was
the last great event in godric life
after Salazar's departure Gryffindor
surely missed his old friend they'd
created so much together and helped the
Wizarding community in innumerable ways
if only Salazar could forget his
obsession with pure Bloods then who
knows what new heights the pair would
have achieved in the years it followed
godric likely passed the seasons in the
same way as he always did teaching the
next Generations of witches and wizards
from within the walls of Hogwarts
watching the seasons change time and
time again eventually Gryffindor died
passing sometime in the 11th century his
legacy and the ideals of courage and
stalwitness became the Bedrock for much
of the Wizarding Community as we know it
today without his contributions to
Hogwarts it's unlikely that the world
could have survived the rise of wizards
like Grindelwald and Voldemort but
perhaps more interestingly the fate of
the greatest gryffindors Harry Potter
and Albus Dumbledore likely would have
turned out far
the lives and Legacies of Hogwarts
Founders are more than enough to fill a
volume or two in Madame Pence's library
at least that's true of most but if we
look past the achievements of godric
Gryffindor Helga Hufflepuff and Rowena
Ravenclaw then you'll be surprised to
find that very little remains of Salazar
Southern and it's important to ask why
after all the lasting impact that
Salazar made from The Wizarding World
the turn of the first Millennium was far
greater than most save only his
co-founders and perhaps the peveral
siblings why then does it seem that
history has chosen to neglect him well I
think we should start at the beginning
all the way back to the 10th century
when he was born what do we know of
Salazar slytherin's early life like his
childhood best friend godric Gryffindor
who he would later join in the
establishment of the world's finest
Wizarding School tells us that the rain
was born in Britain we can't be exactly
sure
but it seems like Salazar's Homeland was
England or Scotland as most historical
texts were recorded on paper parchment a
small detail like Sutherland's
birthplace was rarely marked down and if
it was the document on which It Was
Written didn't survive to the present
day some historians suppose that
Slytherin actually held from Ireland
which means he would have been a fellow
Countryman of the mighty Finkel The
Fearless although Salazar likely moved
from place to place as his parents
Advanced his education or fled
persecution the theory that he was born
in Ireland is a bit more doubtful once
you consider who Southern's greatest
childhood friend was godric Gryffindor
this other founder of Hogwarts was
famously born in the west country of
England and even lent his name into a
village as godric's Hollow was named
after him the very same town that the
Dumbledore family resided in nearly a
thousand years later while the
controversies surrounding Salazar
slytherin's Hometown Remains the man in
which he was raised is far clearer as
you might suspect Slytherin was likely
raised in a family that despised Muggles
it was during his childhood that his
hatred for non-pure Bloods was forged
although it might be simple enough to
consider Salazar's hatred as a simple
inheritance bestowed upon him by his
parents there could be other reasons
England at this time in the 10th century
was filled with the further of the
Anglo-Saxon Christian Church as they
sought to purge the landscape of pagan
idols and their worshipers magical
families were undoubtedly targeted in
the attacks surely part of Salazar's
Prejudice was from a sense of elitism
but in the end he might have simply used
his hatred of purebloods as a way to
cope with the butchering of The
Wizarding World before joining his peers
in the founding of Hogwarts Salazar and
Renown as an accomplished wizard like
other dog whistles throughout history
Salazar said the rain was capable of
communicating with serpents as apostle
tongue he shared this unique trait with
the Creator to the very first basilisk
herpa the fowl and Salazar's own distant
descendant Tom Riddle Salazar would need
this ability when he created the Chamber
of Secrets some time before he was
forced to leave Hogwarts but I'll get to
that story in a bit during his youth
Salazar also famously created his very
own wand a magical Relic that would have
a legacy of a one thousand years old
Salazar originally created the weapon
out of snakewood and even embedded a
tiny piece of a basilisk within it when
we think of the greatest Jewelers of the
time we often turn our attention first
to godra Gryffindor who wielded both a
sword and wand in combat but sutherin
was no slouch either although his
ability to craft ones outside any of his
jewels the weapon eventually became an
heirloom of his family at one point it
made the journey across the Atlantic and
wound up in the new world where it was
eventually transformed into a magical
snake way tree besides his wand Salazar
had trained himself in a number of
magical disciplines as a legitimans the
dark wizard was able to read others
thoughts and even project Visions into
their minds while there aren't many
records about Salazar's particular Feats
with this discipline we can safely
assume that he rivaled the likes of
later Wizards Severus Snape and Lord
Voldemort Voldemort's own feat with
legitimacy while seeming effortless were
great enough to make many consider him
the greatest legitimens of the era he
regularly invaded the minds of his
enemies and was particularly cruel when
he used the skill against Harry Potter
like the earliest dark wizard Herbert
the fowl salazaren had also mastered the
ability of creating a basilisk a giant
venomous serpent that was one of the
deadliest creatures in the Wizarding
World by Harry Potter's time breeding
and holding basilisks in captivity was a
crime that could very well earn you
several years in prison Salazar's
ability this big parcel tongue served
him well in this field basilisks were a
5x class beast and were deemed
impossible to tame that's why dark
Wizards especially those who had a
penchant for parcel tongue were among
the only beings to control the serpents
their ability to communicate with the
giant snakes meant they could at least
steer them in the right direction as you
might suspect salazarin would use this
skill to place a basilisk in the Chamber
of Secrets but again I'm getting a bit
ahead of myself I suppose you might be
wondering when exactly did salazarin get
the idea to create Hogwarts well the
exact dates of Hogwarts founding aren't
quite clear some suggest the year 993
While others claim 990 while nailing
down the school's founding date is
tricky figuring out how old Salazar was
at the time of its creation is even
harder it doesn't seem that historians
concur on any one particular age but it
wouldn't make sense for Salazar to be
much younger his early 30s in order to
help found Hogwarts while joining his
friends godric Gryffindor Rowena
Ravenclaw and Helga Hufflepuff it didn't
seem like the Sutherland's questionable
past raised any questions you have to
remember in later years The Divide
between dark Wizards and their peers was
quite Stark but at this point especially
with the persecution that all the
Wizarding Community faced at the hands
of Mongols slytherin's propensity for
dark magic was demonstrably far less
evil than witch hunts and burnings
located in the Scottish Highlands
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry allowed Salazar a great deal of
Freedom with his unique vision for the
future generations of wizards as each
founder had their own house suthering
decided that he would dedicate his to a
particular type of wizard Southern
didn't Target the recklessly courageous
as Gryffindor did all the senselessly
loyal as Hufflepuff was known to do and
unlike row in a ravenclaw's house which
recruited the smartest of every incoming
class Slytherin preferred the most
cunning he hated Muggles that much we
already knew so slytherin's house
actively discriminated against
muggleborn students during the Sorting
hats ceremony in fact it was in part
thanks to Salazar's skills with charms
that brought the Sorting Hat to life he
along with the other Founders Enchanted
one of godric's old tattered hats and
used it to choose new members of their
respective houses it's hard to know
exactly what Hogwarts look like during
slytherin's time at the school at a 10th
Century Wizarding Academy it must have
been far different than Hogwarts during
Harry or even James Potter's time with
muggle attacks on The Wizarding
Community burning through the country
Salazar must have been a strong
proponent of teaching techniques and
made his students more than capable of
defeating throngs of villagers armed
with simple Steel weapons but as we
mentioned at the very beginning there
isn't much known of The Life and Times
of Salazar Southern and it's in large
part due to how he ended his time at
Hogwarts during the early years of the
school Slytherin eventually butted heads
with his fellow Founders while his dark
Wizarding ways didn't initially bother
godric Helga or Rowena his anti-muggle
rhetoric however right it must have been
at the time didn't sit well with the
others at one point Slytherin laid down
an ultimatum he couldn't imagine a
future for the school if it continued
accepting mugglebone Wizards into the
program even though Southern was given a
great deal of Freedom with his own house
and the Sorting Hat itself aided Salazar
in rejecting non-pure Bloods from his
program the dark wizard wanted more he
wanted every house within Hogwarts to
enroll only the finest pure Bloods and
when this issue eventually came to a
boiling point Slytherin found that his
co-founders wouldn't budge they thought
muggleborns were just as important as
pure Bloods and they couldn't tolerate
slytherin's Prejudice any longer even
Salazar's oldest friend Dave godric
rebuked Slytherin for his intolerance in
the end Salazar felt that he was forced
to abandon Hogwarts the very school that
he had spent so many years helping to
form but he didn't leave the school
unblemished in the years to come the
Sorting Hat would continue to select
students based on Salazar's preferences
and there was one more stain so they're
in Left Behind in the depths of Hogwarts
only accessible by hidden Pathways the
dark wizard had created the Chamber of
Secrets a secret chamber complete with
the Statue of his likeness then as Harry
Drew level with the last pair of pillars
a statue highs the chamber itself loomed
into view standing against the back wall
it was ancient and monkeyish with a long
thin beard that fell almost at the
bottom of the Wizard's sweeping Stone
robes where two enormous gray feet stood
on the smooth chamber floor but that
wasn't the only thing in the chamber
Southern also plays the giant venomous
basil list one that rivaled the
murderous Beast that herpo perfected in
a prior age deep within the dungeon
Salazar hoped that one of his heirs
would take up his charge to rid the
world of muggleborn wizards with the aid
of his serpent his dreams would be
realized one thousand years later when
Tom Riddle accessed the chamber and
attacked his non-pure blood classmates
unfortunately not much is known about
the period after Salazar left Hogwarts
but many believe that he died just a
short period after creating the Chamber
of Secrets
if you think about the greatest founder
of Hogwarts who comes to mind if you
value overall magical abilities you
might be tempted to choose Salazar
Southern after all he created a secret
Enchanted chamber right under the noses
of the three other original teachers at
the school and none of them ever found
out but if you are fascinated by the
legacy of wizards who triumphed over
dark Sorcerers you'd likely suggest
godric Gryffindor the students who
enrolled in his house were among the
strongest Wizards in all of Europe and
in the 20th century the Gryffindor
students who are responsible for
defeating not just Grindelwald but also
the far more terrifying dark wizard Tom
Riddle I'd imagine even a few of you
would throw out Rowena Ravenclaw as your
choice unlike the other Founders Robina
wasn't interested in Courage or pure
blood she chose her students based on
their intelligence the greatest wand
maker in the world the man respond
possible for giving birth Lord Voldemort
and Harry Potter the tools they needed
to Jewel Garrick olivander was actually
a graduate of Rowena's house but I'm
willing to claim that Helga Hufflepuff
the fourth and last founder of Hogwarts
might actually have been greater than
all the rest why well that's what we're
going to talk about today when we look
at her life and Legacy just like the
other founders of Hogwarts Helga
Hufflepuff represented a unique part of
the British Isles godric Gryffindor was
born in the west country of England
robbing a Ravenclaw in the narrow Valley
within the Scottish Countryside and
Salazar Southern in Ireland although
that last part is often contested but
Helga just like one of the most unique
indigenous creatures in Britain the
green Welsh dragons hailed from Wales
although the ancient records of her
hometown have been lost we know that
Helga was raised far away from the urban
trading centers that bordered England
and instead grew up deep within the
Welsh Countryside amidst its flowing
creeks and low Rolling Hills considering
how great of an influence the birth base
of Hogwarts other Founders played in
their roles as teachers it's surprising
to note that helgafulpuff's Welsh
Heritage might have merely been a
footnote for the highly regarded witch
Gryffindor despite his reputation as one
of the most noble Sorcerers of his time
had a particularly bad habit of eagerly
jumping into jewels that trait courage
in the face of possible death was the
very thing the Sorting had to search for
When selecting students for godric's
house and historians have often cited
gryffindor's English Heritage and his
life in the small town that would
eventually bear his name godric's Hollow
as the landscape that molded his bravery
even Slytherin who was rumored to move
about quite often first starting in
Ireland and eventually making his way to
gryffindor's Village was shaped by his
home having faced the sharp tongued
jeers of Muggles who feared the magical
Community Slytherin developed a deep
hatred for any non-magical being this
Prejudice of course later got him kicked
out of Hogwarts but it is another trait
that historians have attached to the
landscape he was raised in wouldn't we
think of Helga Hufflepuff her greatest
attribute was her fair and kind heart
when we talk about her time as a teacher
at Hogwarts we'll dive into what Helga's
fairness actually meant in terms of her
students although we know Helga's
birthplace it's impossible to know her
actual birth date like the other
founders of Hogwarts and pretty much
anyone else from The Wizarding World at
the time surviving parchment records are
hard to come by the best we can do is
look at the founding date of Hogwarts
and deduce how old Helga must have been
at the time now we know that Hogwarts
was established in the year 993 just a
few short years of the turn of the
Millennium certainly Elgar Hufflepuff
was born at least a few decades before
foreign but it's deciphering exactly how
long prior that gets tricky but since we
know that helger godric Salazar and
Rowena often cited as being close
friends then they must have been similar
in age and since most arumen to have
died in the 11th or 12th century it's
likely that Helga was in her 30s or 40s
during the first few semesters which
would make her birth date sometime
around 960 CE as a co-founder of
Hogwarts Hufflepuff must have been among
the greatest witches of her era when we
look at her particular skills we find
the chick sailed at one of the Lesser
celebrated magical disciplines food
charms although it might be quick to
dismiss this art form you'd be wrong to
do so huffle possibility to create
massive feasts and decadent desserts
with her wand wouldn't help in a battle
against dark wizard that's a fair point
certainly but food charms are one of the
most important parts of daily Wizarding
life if you think about about it
carefully you'd realize that the magical
community's ability to quickly
efficiently and hygienically prepare
food throughout the Middle Ages was
something that clearly separated it from
the Muggle World non-magical users often
suffered various diseases and even
plagues throughout much of early history
some sicknesses were caused by spoiled
food while other ailments were spread to
food stores by disease to Vermin it
wasn't until the Advent of modern
medicine during the 20th century and the
technological Revolution that spawned
Refrigeration that food-related
illnesses stopped being a leading cause
of death among children and adults aged
18 to 50 but throughout all of those
centuries the Wizarding Community was
mostly unaffected of course even during
Helga's time healing magic was quite
adapted curing mundane diseases like the
flu or common cold so even if a wizard
contracted to food-related illness it's
likely that they would be able to to
treat it with a few swings of their wand
but that doesn't take away from a simple
fact Hufflepuff pushed food charms far
beyond what they were before her and
likely saved lives doing so her fellow
co-founders obviously valued her magical
contributions when they deemed
Hufflepuff was enough to help them join
in creating Hogwarts and it was during
her time at Hogwarts that Helga's vision
for the future created a legacy that
helped more Wizards than any of her
peers and is the main reason you'd be
right to call her the greatest of them
all as we mentioned earlier part of the
rights given to each founder was how
exactly to pick students for their
respective houses just as each founder
excelled in a particular magical
discipline they each desired their
pupils who reflected that godric valued
courage Salazar favored purebloods and
Rowena accepted the most intelligent
students but Helga was different she
allowed anyone in she didn't hold any
bias against her students and she didn't
allow any of her preconceived notions of
a young boy or girl to get in the way of
how a formal magical education could
transform their future and in that way
Helga touched the lives of thousands of
wizards who would have otherwise been
rejected by the other houses at most
Helga simply wanted good honest children
who would work hard and remain loyal to
their friends even though the other
houses produced far more famous
graduates it's hard to imagine any of
them producing a greater message than
Helga Hogwarts was a school after all
and not a factory for pumping out heroic
Wizards or Evil dark Sorcerers if we
simply analyze Helga Hufflepuff at face
value as a teacher and school founder
then her methods just don't seem like
they can be beat after founding the
school years passed as Helga taught
fresh new faces every fall but just as
godric Gryffindor and Rowena Ravenclaw
would eventually come to understand and
Helga started to feel like one of her
co-founders was meddling in dark magic
in time Salazar Slytherin would approach
the other Founders and request that they
changed their admittance standards
Salazar still deeply scarred by the
torment he likely suffered at the hands
of mughals wanted to bar half-bloods and
muggle Bones from enrolling in Hogwarts
but the other Founders refused to seed
to slytherin's demands and knowing how
staunch egalitarian Hufflepuff turned
out to be it's likely that she was the
one leading the charge against Salazar
eventually Sutherland left the school
and the remaining three Headmasters
carried on without him fortunately for
Helga the rest of her life was
uneventful and the small Schism with
Salazar was the last large confrontation
she had to suffer she passed sometime in
the 11th or 12th century although this
date too has been lost in time when we
look at the legacy of Helga huffle
above's education philosophy and to the
school that bore her name it's easy to
see that in some ways she truly was
ahead of her peers most of the graduates
of house Hufflepuff were level-headed
reasonable young men and women although
many of them never became powerful
Duelists or dark Wizards like the
graduates of Gryffindor or Southern the
Hufflepuff alumni shouldn't be ashamed
of themselves some of them like
Artemisia Lufkin and Grogan stump both
former ministers for magic went on to
better The Wizarding World in
conventional but meaningful ways
Rowena Ravenclaw just like her other
co-founders of Hogwarts represented a
unique part of the British landscape
while godric gryffindorbs from a small
town in the west country of England
Helga Hufflepuff lived in a rural
hell-covered County in Wales and Salazar
suthering was reported to have been born
in Ireland Helga represented Scotland
and called The Highlands her home all
four of them were born in the 10th
Century some decades before they founded
Hogwarts sometime around 990 A.D in the
Years leading to the formation of the
school Rowena had already become
renowned as one of the most skilled
witches of her era her Mastery of charms
which she would later use to create her
famous diadem made her quite a
formidable magic user her thirst for
knowledge pushed her to study magic at a
pace nearly no other wizard or witch
could compete with but it wasn't just
her tenacity that made her a powerful
witch Rowena also possessed an
inexplicable innate connect action to
the magical world which is best
reflected in her dreams
Bryce meeting her co-founders Rowena
would often dream of wild boar in those
dreams the Beast would Wind Through the
Woods and valleys until it drew her to
the foot of a massive dark blue Lake
later in life Rowena took these dreams
as a premonition and used them to guide
her when choosing Hogwarts location
right at the foot of the Great Lake
which many grindelos called home by the
year 990 A.D Rowena had known her fellow
Hogwarts Founders for some time although
Helga Hufflepuff was her closest friend
in the bunch the other two members godra
Gryffindor and Salazar Slytherin were
important to her as well together they
created a Hogwarts School of Witchcraft
and Wizardry and dedicated their lives
to educating the magical youth of
Britain in the ways of The Wizarding
World although the ministry of magic was
still a few centuries away from Croatian
the ancient Britain that Rowena called
home was still ruled by a complex series
of laws with disputes between Muggles
and Wizards always increasing Rowena and
her fellow teachers strived to keep
their students safe and for relatively
short while they achieved just that
as one of the co-founders of Hogwarts
Rowena left a strong impression on the
school in the years it followed her
death the values she instilled continued
making house Ravenclaw every pet is
formidable as it had been during
Rowena's tenure when choosing students
Rowena had a very specific set of
qualities that she looked for unlike God
of Gryffindor who sought courage or
Slytherin who went after pure Bloods
Ravenclaw Wanted only the brightest
students the entire Wizarding World
would come to know just how selective
Ravenclaw was and graduates from a house
would show off their affiliation with
great honor
at some point during her time as a
professor at Hogwarts Rowena's daughter
enrolled at the school we're not quite
sure what Rowena's relationship with the
young girl was like but it's easy to see
that something was wrong
although the historical records never
mention it a second look at Rowena's
life and achievements might tell us all
we need to know about her Merit as a
parent Rowena was ambitious ambitious
enough to devote her time and energy to
the arduous task of creating Hogwarts
she likely worked tirelessly at this
task while Helena was still a young
child something that could have built
animosity between the two and whether
Rowena deliberately sought to burden her
or not the pressure of having one of the
smartest witches in Britain as your
mother was second to none
Helena likely bought a weight of
perfection and studied tirelessly to
live up to her mother's expectations
after all by the time Helena enrolled in
Hogwarts she would need to be smart
enough for her mother to accept her into
her own house Ravenclaw
all this pressure combined with the
Judgment of her peers in The Wizarding
Community drove Helena to present her
mother even more and when Helena finally
acted out the harm was too much for her
mother Rowena to Bear while her daughter
Helena was still a student at Hogwarts
she decided to run away the animosity
between her and her mother had grown too
great overwhelmed by the Adoration her
mother Drew from other Wizards and
witches Helena vowed that she would
become even greater
so she stole her mother's Enchanted
diadem and took off for Albania her
mother's diadem would supposedly
Bewitched so that it granted its wearer
greater wisdom but in the months it
followed Helena's Act of betrayal she
never seemed to grow any wiser back at
Hogwarts Rowena could hardly fathom what
had happened instead of telling her
fellow Founders and enlisting the help
to bring Helena back to safety rowing
ahead the entire ordeal although godric
and Salazar might not have been helpful
Romina wrongly hid the ordeal from Helga
Hufflepuff Helga more than any witch in
The Wizarding World was renowned for her
compassion and her ability to reach out
to troubled magic users but in the end
the shame was simply too much for Rowena
to Bear soon after Helen's departure
Rowena fell ill although she didn't know
it at the time she was dying magical
historians often wonder if Rowena died
from a heartache due to her daughter's
disappear friends such a fate wasn't
uncommon in the ancient magical world
unfortunately we might never know the
truth but in those final days Rowena
made another grave mistake realizing
that her end was drawing near Rowena
wanted nothing more than to see her dear
daughter again even though Helena had
stolen her treasure died um Rowena was
eager to forgive her and hope to hold
her hand as she passed but instead of
calling upon her fellow co-founders for
Aid Rowena turned to a strange Ally the
Bloody Baron known then only as the
baron he was a strange boy he was one of
Salazar slytherin's earliest students
and he was consumed with many of the
same vices that other dark Wizards
possessed but mostly his hot temper
often led him to trouble and ultimately
would be the cause of Helena's death
Rowena turned to the baron for a simple
reason he was obsessed with her daughter
since their time as students at Hogwarts
the baron had tried to make Helena his
spouse but she always refused Rowena
still as sharp as ever knew that the
baron was the one person she could send
to Albania who wouldn't just quit when
the pursuit became too difficult but
Rowena underestimated just how rageful
the baron was when he finally located
Helena in Albania he once again tried to
confess his love but this time when
Helena rejected him the baron withdrew a
razor-sharp dagger and struck her dead
in the end Rowena probably died before
her daughter ever returned as a ghost
when we look at Rowena ravenclaw's
Legacy and all that she accomplished
it's hard not to ignore her personal
failings she created one of the most
disciplined houses at any Wizarding
school and as we've already mentioned
she actually chose the iconic location
before Hogwarts construction a decision
that led to innumerable famous
encounters between students and magical
creatures within the great lake and
Forbidden Forest according to Legend
Rowena even designed the shifting floor
plan which made Hogwarts almost
unchartable unless you had the Marauders
map of course before all these
accomplishments and more Rowena
ravenclawb is easily one of the most
interesting co-founders at Hogwarts but
perhaps the only way to achieve these
great Deeds was to sacrifice her
relationship with her daughter and sadly
that tragedy and the fate of Helen
Ravenclaw is what we'll remember most
about Rowena but one thing is for sure
the Hogwarts fan all of them are widely
thought to have possessed power that was
entirely uncomparable to most modern day
witches and wizards they were all charms
and Transfiguration Masters expert
Duelists pioneers and more the list goes
on they created the perfect environment
for students to become accustomed to
Magic In The Wizarding World as a whole
Hogwarts was a safe place for all that
is after Salazar Slytherin had left but
before Slytherin left the founders put
together an impressive curriculum for
the students of the school truly leaving
no stone unturned when it came to
magical abilities there were 21 subjects
in total astronomy charms dark arts
defense against the dark arts flying
apology history of magic potions
Transfiguration arithmancy care of
magical creatures divination Muckle
studies study of ancient runes Alchemy
ancient studies Apparition art school
studies magical Theory and xylomancy if
you want to learn more about these
subjects then I've got a video on it
called all 21 subjects taught at
Hogwarts which I'll leave a link for in
description whichever way you want to
look at it the founders of Hogwarts made
one of the greatest and longest starting
contributions to wizard kind that we
know of and these four characters were
truly influential in shaping The
Wizarding World into the world that we
know today and that's it for today's
video if you enjoy the content please
like the video and subscribe to the
channel what did you learn about the
history of Hogwarts and its four
Founders leave a comment down below
until next time remember whether you
come back by Page or the big screen
Hogwarts will always be there to welcome
you home